well I'm
invited myself very late in the game
last week I've freed up some time and
thought this is a conference I really
want to in order to go to and I didn't
have much time to slap something
together but I did slap something
together it's a it's very simplistic
it's just an example it's an exercise
it's it's reflecting a way that I think
about tales and climate sensitivity and
some other issues I'm going to just go
through it I try to keep this as
uncomplicated as possible and in the
course there's the Dane in the course of
doing that there's a danger of
oversimplifying in many dimensions okay
so here is the latest summary for policy
added a summary for policymakers and in
the main body of the text and i
paraphrased it a little bit and cut some
stuff out so the latest IPCC ar5
paraphrases that equilibrium climate
sensitivity is likely in the range one
and a half to four and a half degrees
with high confidence it's extremely
likely less than 1 degrees with high
confidence very likely greater than six
degrees centigrade with medium
confidence and in a footnote they added
no best estimate but I mean them by
which they meant a measure of central
tendency no best estimate can now be
given because of a lack of agreement
across assess lines of evidence and
studies and I think that's you know a
loose translation of the committee that
put that together is that we don't want
to go out on a limb because there's too
much uncertainty somehow there ok now
the this this one and a half to a four
and a half degrees centigrade is kind of
like back to jewel Charney in 1979 so
it's like in 30 years time we haven't
much changed this range of climate
sensitivity and it's it's really a
really a pretty big range I don't know
quite what to make of that I I guess
what one has to make of it is that this
is a type of very complicated kind of
science where as you're learning more
and we've learned a tremendous amount
more of course than 1979 your unearthing
more uncertainty at the same some time
as your resolving some other uncertainty
and I guess as you think about it
there's no reason that that can't be the
case it's more likely to be the case i
think in something like climate change
where you're subjectively putting
together a lot of pieces of objective
science sort of impure objective science
i don't know i'm talking over my head
like maybe measuring the speed of light
or something like that we think of
convergence to a more and more to it to
a narrower and narrower range as the
normal way in which science progresses
but there is no reason why this has to
progress that way and it is so turned
out that in 30 years time this iconic
thing this climate sensitivity has not
changed the fourth report of course
which i think was the one that
introduced this uncertainty language
which is very important was almorce got
out slightly more on a limb saying that
it was likely between two and four and a
half degrees centigrade and they named
the measure of central tendency three
degrees this one backed away from that
and and and went back went back to
Charney so I don't you know I'll leave
this as open discussion I don't know
what this means I mean what it means
writ large that you take a particular
measure that happens to be iconic and is
important maybe not the most important
thing by anybody's calculation and there
just is if you reduce it down that just
is no narrowing of uncertainty on the
a key measure I don't know what that
means about the science in general here
whether we can take that as indicative
of degree of uncertainty overall maybe
others will speak to this at least on
this dimension anyway there is there is
no narrowing now what do i do to go to
the next slide okay thank you thank you
okay now what I'm going to do is kind of
playful here I'm going to try to take
IPCC at its word quote unquote all right
and try to fit a distribution to climate
sensitivity now that's one of the things
that's nice to my way of thinking about
climate sensitivity is that people have
gotten out on a limb or organizations
have gotten out on a limb and they've
put out some numbers and of course those
four probabilities of course those
probabilities are loose but we at least
have that to play with it that's an
attractive thing for an economist or at
least for me you can you can you got
some handle on some of this probability
all right so let's look at what what is
going on here I I'm going to focus on
this range between one and a half and
four and a half degrees centigrade the
IPCC said that this was like the likely
arranged the literal interpretation I
was on some of these committees that
talked about probability uncertainty was
very interesting so the likely is
defined by them as being a probability
greater than sixty-six percent right now
you know this leaves a wide range
between sixty-six percent and a hundred
percent and that that gap doesn't get
closed however now maybe I'm reading too
much into these tea leaves but you know
I'm going to do all I can to read the
tea leaves they didn't say that it was
they did not say that it was very likely
between one and a half and four and a
half degrees that would have said it's
ninety percent or or that the
probability is is greater than ninety
percent so I'll say it's somewhere
between
66 and ninety percent reading the tea
leaves and I'll split the difference and
that gives us seventy eight percent
probability you don't like it you can do
something out you know we can do we can
do something else here unfortunately the
answers do depend I'm especially
interested in this tale out here the
answers do depend on the problem the
interpretations alas and the kind of
distribution you're fitting it does
depend on that and maybe that's one of
the takeaway lessons especially when it
comes to these tail things it really can
depend on what you're fitting i think
that message is going to will go through
for more complicated models okay so this
is what I fit I fit a log-normal
distribution to to make it so that it's
it's a capturing seventy-eight percent
of the probability between one and a
half and four and a half degrees and I
made it symmetric so that is an eleven
percent probability that it's less than
one and a half degrees and an eleven
percent probability that's greater than
four and a half degrees all of this
could be of course contested I didn't
want to mess things up by having a whole
bunch of sensitivity analysis of of
different distributions and stuff like
and and different assumptions and stuff
like that it would just look too messy
and I want to get us something central
here why lognormal I think there is a
story why you might want to feel log
normal one the least important maybe is
that it this is a very familiar
distribution and it's the most popular
distribution out there for what it's
worth for non negative quantities but a
deeper reason is this i'm interested in
these upper regions here these are the
worrisome guys and less interested in
this which is less worrisome and what
you're going to get out as probabilities
of higher climate sensitivities is going
to depend very much on the dish under
the fatness of the top or tail
of the distribution and unfortunately
that can matter a lot and if you put a
fat tail distribution instead of a
log-normal you would get bigger than 3.1
percent here right and it would extend
out so if i use the Pareto distribution
of polynomial distribution which is also
well known and used I'd get fatter
distributions out here and more
probability of scary events if I use the
thin tail distribution like a normal I
would get a much lower probability
shrinking very rapidly to zero as I come
out on these higher sensitivities the
log-normal is unique in the sense that I
mean I don't know what if there's an
underlying theorem at some mathematical
statistician has proved but the
log-normal is neither fat nor thin or
both fat and thin because the log normal
distribution every moment of it I don't
want to get too technical but every
moment exists for log normal
distribution which means it's going to
zero faster than any polynomial or any
polynomial of any order at the same time
it's muscle called moment generating
function which is the integral of its
probability time something of the form e
to the 80 that is infinity so it is it
so the log normal distribution is in
between it's slower converging than an
exponential and it's faster converging
than any polynomial and I don't know
that seemed like a good sort of cop
along with its familiarity compromise to
this I know what's going to happen
because I've done it for these other
distributions and unless it will it will
matter let me just take a look at some
of the other things that IPCC said they
said that so I'm fitting in between here
is consistent with IPCC they said that
it's extremely unlikely that it's less
than one degree so that's a probability
of less than five percent what comes out
of this log normal distribution is one
point seven percent so that's consistent
with that also if they'd wanted to use
the line
language of virtually it's virtually
certain that that climate sensitivity is
greater than one degree then that means
a probability is less than one percent
that it's less than one degree they
didn't use that language so I'm this is
fitting this is consistent at this end
there's some sort of an inconsistency I
think loosely speaking because their own
this say and this is the end that they
themselves a quote unquote themselves
must understand is more important than
this they must understand it's more
important to understand this then to
understand this as it were and what
they're saying is that it's very
unlikely that it's greater than six
degrees well that only means probability
less than ten percent they could have
used the language it's extremely
unlikely which I think would have been
more consistent but they didn't that
would have been made at less than five
percent in any event the log-normal that
I'm fitting gives a three point one
percent probability of being greater
than six degrees I just want it so i
don't i'm not quite sure what's going on
what's going on here maybe they
literally meant that this is seven
percent or something like that that
would imply if i try to fit it with this
eleven percent here a very fat tailed
distribution just on those two points I
don't know what's going on okay the only
I don't know what's what's happening the
only thing is that the that I want to
point out is that what i'm doing here is
very conservative right it's i don't i'm
not stacking the deck in any way I don't
think shape or form to get high climate
sensitivities by this and I think that
most people would agree even people who
believe climate sensitivity should be
low they haven't got a lick they have
got to like to stand on to argue
vehemently about whether this is three
percent or not so far as I understand
the literature okay now okay now here is
what I'm going to do I'm going to define
a catastrophe
I gotta move along as being six degrees
centigrade or higher that's ridiculous
on many grounds at four degrees you
could catastrophe itself i'd have to
define a catastrophic climate change it
means somehow very high damages it could
occur at four degrees the damages as a
function of temperature itself as a
probability distribution and what the
damages are is going to depend on how
fat that probability distribution is as
a function of temperature but just to
make things simple I'll identify six
degrees is catastrophic and leave
everything else out of the picture what
happens here then is that what you
notice out of all these kinds of
exercises is of course we've got a
probability distribution on climate
sensitivity we plug in the greenhouse
glass con co2e concentrations and you
pull out a probability distribution of
the temperature increase so we're now at
450 approximately some estimates for
example the IEA is estimating that will
end up somewhere around 650 based on
pledges coming out of Copenhagen which
themselves are very loose this might be
interpreted as an optimistic scenario
actually if you take everybody at their
word for what they pledged with and it
wasn't or whatever the word is it's not
binding if take everybody at their word
I they and sort of try to extrapolate or
something like that they come up with
somewhere around 650 what I find
disturbing to the point of alarming is
how this chance of catastrophe defined
admittedly in this narrow way goes up a
lot as the co2 e concentrations go up
sup you concentrate on the median
doesn't quite look so worrisome you
concentrate on this it does look look
worrisome now this is this is just
chapter one so to speak of something
that's at least three chapters three
chapters long in order to
to say what the implications are that
we've got to go through at least two
other things one is what are the damages
associated with this thing I just put it
down as a catastrophe and something to
be avoided I don't know the answer we
economists don't know the answer when we
get out of a range of about two degrees
centigrade is so as you can as anybody
can imagine of the new comments to know
this there's a sense this look we don't
know what you know is very serious
things could start to happen six degrees
is a planet that biologically would be
unrecognizable but even if four degrees
some things could happen it's a depend
on the tail distributions of that okay
so you got to somehow talk about the
damages I'm leaving it in this form one
nice thing about splitting it this way
is that I'm leaving it as a temperature
you plug it in your own head what you
think 6 degrees might mean or four
degrees or whatever then there's this
nasty issue of timing and discounting
because if you just look at this it's
horrifying with this chance of six
degrees if that were going to happen in
50 years over holding the time constant
even a hundred years the time constant
at which this occurs it looks like a
horrifying picture but of course the cat
is the high temperatures anyway are
occurring if they occur at all further
and further out in the future so you got
this I think I hope I'm setting the
stage so he's I'm starting off with with
climate sensitivity looks worrisome then
there's these other ingredients that we
economists add into the picture the main
tool what are the damages associated
with something like this and then he is
the timing and discounting you're
talking if it's 6 degrees centigrade you
really are talking about several
centuries from now when it comes into
equilibrium so you really got to go back
to dynamics put in timing and
discounting these are immensely
controversial subjects if we have more
time and discussion we we can we can
talk about that I'm not absolutely
positive that when we're
trying to measure damages from climate
change that it fits very well with an
expected present discounted utility or
something like that maybe this is a
different kind of a good having rights
or what's what's sometimes called a
merit good or something right in any
event here this issue raises its ugly
head and so to make these extreme things
matter you've gotta in earlier work I
didn't pay enough attention to this and
bill corrected and he was absolutely
right you got a combined stuff so to
make this count the story somehow come
on you got to combine it with with some
damages that are high at these high
temperatures you're going to make these
damages high at high temperatures was
some part of the tale of damages hi at
high temperatures you've got to somehow
apply as well it's going to depend on
the discounting an ordinary discounting
even catastrophic things two hundred
years from now don't look so
catastrophic in terms of present value
so you somehow gotta talk or walk your
way around this discounting issue okay
that I think I think I'm trying to lay
out what my way of looking at this thing
this is alarming bothersome I'd say it
really is bothersome if you go into this
range where I'm afraid that's probably
where we're heading this just looks too
damn high and if it's happening a couple
hundred years from now but somehow to
get to tame this beast more we got to
get into this realm and this realm is
kind of ugly with subjectivity you might
you might you might say thank you very
much